ciao e benvenuto in un nuovissimo oggi
risponderò alle vostre supposizioni nei
miei confronti a tutte quelle cose che
pensate di sapere su di me in questi
giorni infatti su instagram vi ho
chiesto di iscrivermi delle affermazioni
o delle appunto supposizioni che vi
siete fatti in questi anni seguendomi
sulla mia vita sul mio modo di
affrontare insomma le cose le cose
brutte e sulle mie passioni eccetera
eccetera
quindi oggi affermerò o negherò tutte
queste supposizioni
prima di partire col video però la
comunicazione importantissimo da farvi
siete pronti il tour del firma copie di
cuore corazza sta per sbarcare
[Musica]
sono felicissimo perché finalmente vengo
a roma incontrarvi e da tantissimo tempo
che mi chiedete una data a roma quindi
segnatevi tutti questa data sabato 9
marzo cioè il saluto che sta per venire
alle ore 16 a partire dalle ore 16 alla
libreria mondadori di via tuscolana 771
io non vedo l'ora di abbracciarti quindi
non mancate e ti aspetto
partiamo subito con la prima cosa che
pensate di sapere su di me sei rifatta
no perché questa supposizione non sono
rifatto non ho niente di fatto
alcuni di voi mi hanno chiesto se l'è
fatto gli zigomi
no sono miei naturali e per adesso non
mi sono mai fatta neanche punturine cose
varie quindi sono proprio natur come mi
vedete come mamma l'ha fatto
ami molto gli animali e vorresti un cane
ebbene sì è verissimo amo gli animali o
un nipotino quattro zampe da quattro
mesi che ha preso la mia sorella e mi
sono follemente innamorata e a maggior
ragione ancora di più so pensando
insomma di fare questa scelta di
prendere un canale con me anche se
comunque la responsabilità è molto
impegnativo e voglio pensarci bene
essere molto sicura non ti butti giù al
primo ostacolo più o meno
nel senso che inizialmente tendo ad
andare in dow quindi a più termine
stessa pena vedere tutto nero per magari
un giorno 2 dopo di che riesco sempre a
trovare la forza per andare avanti e per
cercare di superare quell'ostacolo che
non ti chiami marina è vero non mi
chiamo marina con la y
mi chiamo marina senza y tanti di voi lo
sapranno il mio nome è vero e marina
quella di normale ho deciso di mettere
questa y per differenziare un po la
marina ragazza dalla marina personaggio
pubblico diciamo una delle tue passioni
più grandi e il canto assolutamente sì
chi mi segue su instagram avrà visto che
pubblico spesso cover storie qui canto
adoro ovviamente la musica e mi piace
tantissimo cantare
tant'è che uno dei miei sogni ancora
insomma di fare una canzone di diventare
una cantante perché no e chi ha detto
cuore corazza il mio romanzo avrà
intuito qualcosa quindi assolutamente
sic sei molto emotiva sì questa è una
caratteristica del mio fantastico segno
zodiacale il cancro che emotivo lunatico
sensibile ecco io sono perfettamente
linea con le caratteristiche del mio
segno e sono così tanto emotiva che
spesso mi capita magari di vedere delle
pubblicità in tv a piangere fatti
populista che non dovrebbero fare
piangere ma io mi emoziono
basta niente promozionale anche magari a
volte sono i m in giro e vedo lo so dure
critiche stimolo per la mano e mi
sarebbe contrappone qui la piantino sono
fatto così sei molto e disorganizzata e
fai tutto all'ultimo minuto anche questo
è super vero purtroppo
io vi assicuro che è da anni anni a ne
fosse dal liceo che io ogni anno le
compro un'agenda ea fine anno
quell'agenda è completamente cota non
c'è scritto niente perché chi mi
riprometto di organizzarvi tutti gli
animi per i vari appuntamenti e così la
volta poi allunga però neanche cioè o la
pila di agente così degli anni passati
mai utilizzati io sono proprio la
disorganizzazione fatta persona mangio
un sacco anche se sei magra come un
chiodo
allora innanzitutto ci tengo a precisare
questa cosa visto che spesso me lo
dicono sotto le foto che sono troppo
magra sono veramente così i costituzione
infatti chi vi segue vedere storie vede
che mangio sempre un sacco
sono fortunata ho un metabolismo chi
lavora molto bene e quindi tutto quello
che mangio a quanto pare lo brucio ci
sono rimasta abbastanza male quando è
capitato di leggere sotto le mie foto
siano resti delle ossa mangia le ossa
leviamo ai cani questi commenti
veramente imbarazzante ridicoli
innanzitutto perché appunto come ho
appena detto sono fatta così di
costituzione quindi non posso non lo
decido io
seconda cosa ricordiamoci che anoressia
bulimia
tutti questi problemi legati al cibo
sono problemi seri gravi determinati
soprattutto da fattori psicologici non è
assolutamente un argomento sul quale
scherzare insultare e un argomento dhabi
mire con un commento preti minori su
instagram quindi evitate di farlo sei
stata adottata
no anche se fosse
non ci sarebbe nessun problema perché
sono super favorevole alle adozioni o
una vita che è stata adottata quindi so
cosa vuol dire so quanto siano
coraggiosi e pieni d'amore i genitori
che decidono insomma di allargare la
loro famiglia di adottare un bambino
nonostante non ci sia un legame di
sangue e so anche quanto possono essere
fortunati i bambini che vengono accolti
in in una situazione di questo tipo
perché spesso sono tolti da situazioni
difficili nelle quali non avrebbero
assolutamente avuto modo di ricevere
amore di crescere come ogni bambino si
merita di crescere in passato si è stata
più timida e introversa di ora sì e no
nel senso che su alcuni aspetti da
ragazzina ero più timida introversa su
altri no rendo conto sempre più
crescendo che ero molto più sfrontata di
adesso vi faceva molti meno problemi
adesso può forse per insomma lavoro che
faccio il contesto in cui mi trovo
spesso devo un attimo filtra e quello
che penso perché come sapete sono molto
diretta
quindi per evitare problemi perché
discussioni spesso magari qui tengo
dentro quello che penso i tuoi sono
divorziati da quando sei piccola sì nel
senso che si sono separati quando io ero
molto piccola forse 12 anni non ricordo
e poi più di recente ha divorziato dei
spagnola per metà nel senso che mia
mamma italiana è mio ma forte spagnolo
si sono conosciuti a londra
ovviamente quando erano giovani e per
questo motivo io parlo sia italiano che
spagnolo quindi per tutti coloro che non
lo sapessero visto che spesso magari
faccio stories in spagnolo video in
spagnolo papa parla spagnolo quindi l'ho
imparato in questo modo non ho mai
studiato diciamo chi descrive una sola
parola vera tutto grazie perché è una
delle cose che vi rende più orgogliosa
sapere che sono riuscita a farvi vedere
da voi per quello che sono veramente
nonostante insomma faccia tanti
personaggi dei miei video di mascheri ac
abitazioni
l'importante è che sia uscita la sera me
questa cosa mi riempie il cuore di gioia
penso che sui social sia fondamentale se
stessi perché per quanto uno possa
fingere di essere qualcosa che non è
prima o poi la verità viene sempre a
galla e ci vuole un attimo perché la
maschera casa per tenere si rompe mille
pezzi facendo vedere quello che si cena
veramente nuova tassa inizialmente
sembri una che se la tira ma poi
conoscendoti non è affatto così
allora
questa è una cosa che prima insomma di
affaccia nel mondo dei social succedeva
spesso nelle mie relazioni
interpersonali
la maggior parte dei miei amici dei miei
passati ragazzi mi dicevano sempre più
utenti ho visto in quanto lo ha fatto
sentire questa poi conoscendo ti ho
cambiato completamente idea
ecco io non ho mai capito bene questa
cosa ma forse adesso a distanza di anni
la verità è che appunto io spesso una
corazza un po da stronza un po da dura
che uso utilizzo per cercare di
proteggermi perché non su una persona
che non si fida sono molto diffidente e
quindi detto questo scudo tra me e gli
altri
e la cosa è veramente bello molto
difficile e che soltanto chi ma dietro
lo scudo riesce a conoscermi veramente e
e quelli invece che si fermano davanti
allo scudo e girovita che se ne vanno
via evidentemente non hanno questo
grande interesse di conoscerli ed è
meglio perderli che trovarli
secondo me sei una persona che cerca di
coprire le debolezze e vuole sempre
portare positività
sì è vero tanti di voi mi chiedono come
fa essere sempre così carica così
positiva così felice la mia risposta è
no non lo sono sempre anche io e miei
momenti no ma non voglio tra vidoletti
con di condividerli con voi non voglio
farvi vedere le mie debolezze perché
perché voglio cercare di trasmettere
sempre positività e forza chi mi segue
sei super gelosa
immagino che chi affitto questa questa
affermazione intenda quei ragazzi
come sapete ho fatto tanti video sulla
gelosia sulle ragazze gelose c'è sempre
scherzato e riso su perché è una cosa
che bene o male riguarda tante ragazze
però se vi devo dire la verità forse una
volta quasi più piccole non può più
gioiose adesso non lo sono più e secondo
me la gelosia delle ragazze di bene
tanto da persona con quest anno perché
in passato ho avuto ragazzi che non mi
davano insomma sicurezza è infatti ero
ero gelosa perché avevo magari più dubbi
non mi fidavo cifra eccetera
adesso ho un ragazzo che non mi fa
dubitare di niente non ha segreti
mi fido di lui al 100 per cento e
infatti non sono gelosa quindi penso che
tutta questa gelosia delle ragazze
dipende essenzialmente dalla persona che
ama fianco quando era adolescente non
accettava il tuo corpo
il vero quando ero adolescente euro
forse dieci chili in più e non mi
piacevo assolutamente anche perché le
mie compagne erano tutte magre con i
fisici perfetti di pelle toni che ci
provavamo i costumi e io guardavo lo
ricevo perchè non sono così e così è
tutto normalissimo ragazzi è
normalissimo durante l'adolescenza avere
dei chili in più erano lì per i brufoli
perché è un periodo di transizione della
nostra vita
quindi non vi fate problemi inutili il
consiglio che vi posso dare se siete
insomma nel mezzo l'adolescenza e non
andate d'accordo con il vostro corpo è
innanzitutto di concentrarvi sui vostri
pregi e sappiate che questo è un periodo
di transizione il vostro corpo e non
rimarrà così il vostro corpo multerà e
non potete sapere in quale farfalla
meravigliosa vi tramite rete
sei una persona molto selettiva ai pochi
veri amici assolutamente sì c'è un
periodo della mia vita in cui avevo
tantissimi amici tre quarti dei quali
falsi come giuda
quindi dopo tutte le delusioni e tutti
gli amici insomma che mi hanno tradito
ho deciso proprio questa decisione
meglio pochi ma buoni quindi sì ho pochi
amici ma super buoni e li tengo stretti
perché sono davvero preziosi hai scritto
un libro si è uscito da pochissimo si
chiama cuore corazza è un romanzo una
storia e sono fierissimo di questo
progetto perché era uno dei sogni che
insomma volevo realizzare
sto ricevendo tantissimi messaggi su che
positivi il libro vi sta piacendo
tantissimo e io sono veramente veramente
felice allora la supposizione più
gettonata è questa scritta ovviamente in
modi diversi perché sono stato in
tantissimi a scrivere vera nella vita è
passato molte disavventure che però che
ha aiutato a crescere ad essere più
forte che ho passato molte disavventure
vero che ho avuto dei periodi veramente
veramente bruttini anche più che grazie
alla mia ironia
penso che sia più stato alla forza che a
un certo punto è scattata dentro di me
la forza insomma di il cambiamento di
riuscire a non farli più praticamente
schiacciare a determinate situazioni di
non farmi più mette i piedi in testa da
nessuno di essere me stesso al cento per
cento è lottare per i miei sogni perché
solo io posso farlo e ma ho bisogno di
nessun altro
la piccola si è stata pulita sì anche io
insomma ho vissuto episodi di bullismo è
un argomento delicatissimo di cui oggi
grazie a dio si parla molto soprattutto
grazie ai social anche se proprio grazie
ai social
si è diffuso ancora di più sappiamo
tutti che cos'è il cyberbullismo sapete
chi è un argomento che mi sta molto a
cuore di cui parlo spesso bisogna
parlarne tantissimo perché bisogna
provare a combatterlo non è possibile
che sia così diffuso e che soprattutto
rovini le vite a tantissimi ragazzini
so che tanti di voi sono insomma vittime
di bullismo che lo scrivete spesso in
direct nei messaggi quello che posso
consigliare dal profondo del cuore happy
parlarne o con i vostri genitori con con
dei vostri amici o con gli insegnanti
non dovete assolutamente avere paura di
parlarne perché non è giusto quello che
state stupendo non dovete essere vittime
di nessuno quindi parlarne e non
sentitevi mai in colpa perché non avete
fatto niente di male siete perfetti così
come siete e nessuno si deve permettere
di insultarvi e di farvi del male
verbale o fisico siamo arrivati
purtroppo alla fine del video spero
tantissimo che vi sia piaciuto e che
abbiate avuto modo insomma di conoscervi
un po meglio se questo video vi è
piaciuto vi chiedo per favore di
lasciarli un bel like e se non vi siete
ancora iscritti al canale
iscrivetevi e cliccate sulla capparella
che trovate vicino un tasso di
iscrizione per ricevere una notifica a
tutte le volte che pubblico un nuovo
video ricordatevi note dell'appuntamento
di sabato 9 marzo alle ore 16 alla
mondadori di via tuscolana 771 a roma
non vedo l'ora di vedervi seguiteli
tutto utile a the social facebook
instagram ei tic toc e soprattutto su
instagram perché comunicherò tutte le
prossime date dei firma copie proprio lì
vi mando un bacione norme spadaro ciao
[Musica]
[Applauso]